hello there today we'll look at fast
former additive attention can be all you
need by chuwan wu fung chow woo tao chi
and yong feng huang so this paper
definitely wins out in the category of
most innovative paper titles of the last
few months
as apparently we've gone from is all you
need to can be all you need so a big win
on this front as you might have guessed
from this title the paper is introducing
a new kind of attention mechanism if you
don't know what an attention mechanism
is and you're in machine learning
you might want to find out i have a
paper video on attention is all you need
so the new attention here is additive
attention
which is supposed to be a much much much
faster way of doing attention thus the
name fast former
this additive attention circumvents this
quadratic bottleneck that we usually
have in the attention mechanism instead
of doing sort of multiplicative
attention they do
what they call additive attention now
the naming in my opinion is a bit
confusing and the whole concept is a bit
confusing so on a high level that's what
they do they design a new attention
mechanism my opinion of the paper is
that it's kind of uh
deceptively naming things to make it
appear like it's an attention mechanism
where in reality it seems to be sort of
a
just sort of a
feed-forward-ish layer type of thing
that they propose
maybe not even so you know we'll go into
that uh their promises are that of
course at circumventing this quadratic
bottleneck of attention you can input
much longer sequences into the
context of a transformer and you can do
it also much faster for the same length
of sequences since everything is just
additive and not multiplicative when i
find that out they claim they have a lot
of experimental evidence and yeah if you
like content like this you know don't
hesitate to subscribe if you haven't
done so already
so the
abstract reads um
transformer are very powerful okay
however the attention mechanism is
inefficient due to the quadratic
complexity to input sequence length they
say although there are many methods on
transformer acceleration they are still
either inefficient on long sequences or
not effective enough by effective i
guess they mean uh
their performance suffers too much
so they say they propose fast former an
efficient transformer model based on
additive attention so instead of
modeling the pairwise interactions
between tokens which is what attention
does we first use additive attention
mechanism to model global contexts and
then further transform each token
representation based on its interaction
with the global context representations
now if this sounds confusing to you
it does so to me too
they go a little bit into more detail
right here they say they have this
additive attention
uh which is linear complexity instead of
quadratic as in usual transformers
so here is a bit more detail we use
additive attention to summarize the
input attention query matrix into a
global query vector then we model the
interaction between the attention key
and the global query vector via
elementwise product to learn the global
context aware key matrix
we further summarize it into a global
key vector via additive attention
then we use element wise product to
aggregate the global key and attention
value
which are further processed by a linear
transformation to compute the global
context aware attention value
finally we add together the original
attention query and the global context
aware attention value to form the final
output you know still after this
paragraph doesn't make too much sense to
me to understand um so we'll go to the
diagram in just one second
but here is essentially what they
promise
okay they propose an additive
attention-based transformer named fast
former to our knowledge
fast former is the most efficient
transformer architecture so that's one
they propose the most efficient
transformer architecture
second we propose to model the
interaction between global context and
token representations we element wise
product which can help fully model
context information an efficient way
okay so the the element wise product
seems to be the second component so
there's additive attention uh there is
element wise product and then lastly
they say you know our experimental data
sets uh valid validate our approach
all right so here is the coveted diagram
of the fast former it's a little bit
complicated but i want to go back a
little bit to the regular attention
mechanism i know i've done this a lot
but i think in this context it is really
worth discussing so in a regular
attention mechanism what do you have you
have some sort of an input sequence each
one of these things can be
a a vector some sort of an embedding
vector or something like this but it's a
sequence essentially it's a set but we
think of it as a sequence of let's say
tokens in natural language and we want
to transform the sequence of one layer
into a sequence of equal length of the
next layer so
if we stack many of these layers
together we sort of want to improve the
representations of these tokens layer by
layer by layer such that we can at the
end of the transformer understand what
each token means in the context of all
other tokens so if this is a sentence
my
house is
very green
then
at the at the beginning each word is
just an isolated piece of data at the
end of these transformations we want
sort of all the tokens to uh to be aware
of all the other tokens in the input and
uh sort of capture their in-context
meaning
now
what we need to do is we need to
transform one
set of
representations into the next one the
way we do this is by the attention
mechanism so the attention mechanism
essentially from each of the tokens it
derives three different things one is
called a key so the key is a vector so
the key
is a vector for each token and that
vector describes kind of like what the
content of this token is so far okay so
one vector is the key
which allows the token to advertise what
it has to offer the other one is the
query
which allows each token and that's also
derived from the same token but i'm
going to draw it up here the query
means what does this token want to know
about the other tokens in the sequence
so this can be different from its
content so as you see the query and the
key they might be different there are
variants where this the same but
usually you derive two different values
from each token and then what we do is
we route by inner product so you for
every single query you aggregate across
the entire input sequence sequence you
aggregate
by inner product which means that this
would get routed here by a lot this one
may be two these ones not so much and so
on so you
aggregate essentially the inner product
which for each query gives you a
histogram a histogram across the
sequence saying okay this information
here is mildly relevant this one is more
relevant this one is slightly relevant
these ones aren't relevant at all for me
this histogram you then normalize via a
soft max operation
and that gives you
i mean that gives you a real
distribution over the input so with the
query and the key you decide how you
want to aggregate the information in the
input sequence for one particular
element in the output sequence you do
this for every element so for every
element you get a distribution of how
you want to aggregate and then in the
last step
every single item also emits what's
called a value and the value is yet
another vector and the value i guess you
don't even have to actually transform
anything the value you can just take the
information itself
of the token if you want but essentially
the value is ultimately what you
multiply together with this distribution
and then that becomes your next layer
representation for this particular token
all right so the whole query key
attention mechanism is simply to decide
how do i want to aggregate the
um the different values of the input
sequence for any given token in
the next layer
all right
okay i hope this is clear so the the
query the key advertises what the
contents are
which is kind of like the value the
value is the actual contents but the key
is more like an addressable
representation of the content and the
query uh emits what do i want to know
about the others so you won't match the
queries of myself with the key of the
others and that aggregates now in that
context let's look at the fast former so
we said there are two elements there is
first of all there is this additive
attention and that's what you can see
kind of down here so you see there's the
input and the input gets transformed
into three different things into queries
keys and values that is just like a
regular attention mechanism these are
linear
transformations that each token
independently goes through so this token
independently produces this this query
this key and this value and with the
same transformation this token produces
this query this key and these this value
so there's no interaction every token
goes through the same transformation
then
you can see instead of now considering
the interactions between each of the
queries and each of the keys sorry that
should probably be up here instead of
considering this interaction we don't do
that what we do first is we say well
this really becomes quadratic if we do
if we consider interaction between each
query and each key
therefore
let's simply construct one global query
okay one global query and then we
consider the interaction of that global
query with each of the keys instead of
um
instead of uh doing
everything with everything so here is
you where here
you can see how the linearness instead
of the quadraticness of this approach
comes to be instead of considering
pairwise interactions we simply
construct a single query vector by the
way this is all this is one head so this
is one head uh
usually a transformer has multiple heads
so over here you would have like head
number two and so on had number three
head number four but in a single head we
make one query vector
um
yeah and you immediately see what the
shortcomings are here
whereas previously
every token could sort of dynamically
decide how it wants to aggregate
information and every token could do
that
you know in a in a sort of by itself now
it's only the sequence as a whole that
gets to decide how it wants to aggregate
information because it needs to come up
with a combined query vector so i'm
going to guess this thing here works
might work quite well for tasks that
have sort of a single
single-minded output sort of topic
classification or something like this
where you simply you know the global
information is necessary usually whereas
tasks that might be more you know
nuanced and language relevant like
considering specific interactions
between individual tokens and so on uh
those might fall a lot short in this
approach
okay but how how does this
single query vector come to be
now this single query vector is
constructed purely as you can see from
the queries of the individual token
elements
how there's this funny construction here
where you have you can see this is the
query vector right here and then it
itself goes here
and here so it's used twice okay so
we what we do is we construct this alpha
value for each query vector and then we
multiply that alpha value by the query
vector itself and then we add this is an
addition here we add
all together at the end so essentially
this query vector here the global one is
a weighted sum across all of the
individual query vectors now the
question is you know how do we side
decide on the weight and that's where
these alpha values come in so let's see
oh yeah here is the formulas for the
alpha values so each query vector
q i
um will produce
the its own alpha i how is that computed
as you can see right here this should be
familiar to you this is the softmax
formula so what we do is we
it's also the formula for
logistic regression if you squint a
little bit um so
essentially the alpha i's
are the result of a soft max operation
across the queries so you have query one
query two query three
right
it's a softmax across not the queries
itself but this quantity right here the
query multiplied by some sort of a
transformation and this now really looks
like logistic regression this w here is
a vector that is learned this is a
learned parameter vector right i take
the inner product with each of the
queries
and that gives me like a number right
and then what i do is i simply normalize
this by
all the numbers of all the queries okay
so
every one of these gets
multiplied by this w
which gives me one number and then i
simply normalize i i
push it through the exponential function
then i normalize it this is essentially
a logistic regression
with the w being the feature vector
okay now what does it mean what does
this mean okay like we construct the
final query vector as an aggregate
across all query vectors with the
weightings being
dependent on
like a soft max or a logistic regression
with respect to this learned vector w
this is always the same right for for
every one of those queries uh
i can make sense of that if i think okay
this is the w here is essentially
um you know in logistic regression you
classify so the w vector me is the sort
of the classification boundary of
you know the one class versus the other
class so
this here i think is essentially a
little classifier that cares about one
particular thing that is learned so this
can be some intermediate feature
that is useful that is learned via back
propagation in this w vector and
the weighting of this particular head in
this particular layer is then according
to that feature okay so in here
there is somewhere there is a w vector
and that w vector in this particular
layer for this particular head
refers to some kind of useful feature
like
i don't know like is there then a name
of a country somewhere in the sentence
okay
and that's what we use
as a way to aggregate the queries
so um
you can immediately see that if a term
if
you know a token
um it's if it's query sort of contains a
country
information
this classifier would
you know
say well
that particular query has a lot of the
information that i particularly look for
in this layer therefore the inner
product will be high therefore the alpha
will be high therefore that particular
query would be represented greatly in
the global query vector so the global
query vector essentially you can think
of i select among all the query vectors
the ones that i care about in this
particular layer in this particular head
however
what you care about in this layer in
this head is static it's statically
learned it's the same for every single
sample okay
all right so this is sort of a weighing
by particular feature
now once we have the global query vector
right here how do we let it interact
with the key vector so usually what we
do is we do an inner product of the
query and the key and then that defines
sort of our aggregation distribution
however since we only have a single
query you know that will not give us
that will in fact not give us an
an n dimensional c uh sorry an n
length sequence as here that will only
give us a sequence of length one in the
next layer so we can't really do that so
what they do is they almost do an inner
product except they don't sum right they
do simply
element-wise multiplications of the
queries and the keys now element-wise
multiplication it kind of means um
so it means
you know like the element-wise
multiplication if you think of it if
both elements are small the result is
very small if and if both are high the
result is very high so there's some
non-linear dynamics going on within the
same dimension right there's no
aggregation across dimensions um
and
yeah so
they do element wise multiplication
right here in order to obtain these p
vectors and the p vectors they are now
the integration each every p
vector
p vector so p i
is equal to the element-wise
multiplication of the i of key vector
with the global query vector okay
so
yeah
and the queer the query vector itself is
of course
a
sum
across
a weighted sum across all of the queries
so if i pull the k in you can see that i
still
have
okay alpha j
i still have this quadratic thing here i
still have for you know
i get i have n uh p vectors uh and for
each one i have also n q vectors and i
consider products of the form i j so i
still have the quadratic products in
here however
i don't have quadratic complexity why
because i don't have a soft max in
between aggregating the queries
and aggregating the keys and therefore
uh you know the
what is the commuted associative rule
applies and i can simply get away with
first aggregating the query and then
multiplying
it as a whole by the keys now of course
that are those are two linear operations
in sequence whereas in the normal
attention mechanism i have a linear
operation then a non-linear one with the
softmax and then again a linear one and
arguably the non-linearities is what
brings the whole power to deep learning
so uh you know
this essentially
here you can see how it really
circumvents the quadratic bottlenecks by
simply saying well if everything's
linear
then there you know we can we can just
add all together
uh yeah that's the trick essentially
now then
you you realize we're not done yet okay
what do we do with the p vectors well
this seems familiar right again we do
another one of these additive attentions
so they call this thing additive
attention you can see from each p1 we
produce a beta value the beta value
exactly the same way as the alpha values
i suppose at least yes you can see that
right here
right the beta value is exactly the same
for each p
we multiply it by a learned
feature
vector which is wk right here
and then we normalize by all of them and
you know after the exponential function
and then we aggregate the global key
via again a weighted sum of all of these
p vectors so this is again additive
attention in order
in order to have a global key vector
and now
exactly the same trick we use the global
key vector element-wise multiplied by
the value vectors which gives us these u
vectors right here that these apparently
go through another linear transformation
uh to give us the r vectors
um you know you can
you can stack as many linear
transformations as you want
and
then we're we're still not done right
we're still not done so essentially
what we've done
in the end is we we
we take the values
which is the information we want to
forward propagate and for each value
we
element-wise multiply it uh with this k
vector and this k vector is a result of
the keys and also this query vector and
that's a result of the
the cues
so essentially
there is no aggregation of information
as is there in the regular transformer i
don't aggregate the values from the
sequence in a weighted fashion i simply
leave each value
as it is you know these are as i said
these are transformations that don't
depend on the other sequence elements so
v1 purely depends on e1 and the only way
the only way that
token information from the other tokens
can come into any token is via this
aggregation methods
right here in in that in the
normalization constant right
in in in the aggregation uh that happens
via the normalization
you know for example
the key n
could
be represented more in this global key
and then that's multiplied
here
to my
vector 1. so that's how other
information comes into any particular
token
and as i said we're still not done after
we obtain these r vectors
we then add to them
this thing right here we add to them the
query vectors again now why i don't know
but we just do
so we simply add the query vectors to
the um
r
vectors that we have here
and that's going to be our final output
so this is
stupidly complex and i don't think for
any particular reason so there are
multiple problems right here for example
this transformation right here is a
linear transformation
um
i okay maybe it makes sense but it seems
like you just had a linear
transformation here and this whole sum
here is sort of a linear
aggregation
ergo yeah okay maybe you can justify
that but
second of all this connection right here
right if this is not
ablated in the experiment like i don't
believe squat here um like
i want to know how much this this is
clearly not something you do from the
beginning this is clearly something you
add after the other stuff don't doesn't
work so i want to see an experiment
where this connection is missing
to decide and i want to see an
experiment where only this connection
happens to decide
you know where the actual work is going
here then another thing you can see this
here the the middle column is entirely
useless like like this
this right here
it simply it simply the lower part is a
repetition from
sorry the upper part here is a
repetition from the left so these two
things are repeating
um and then the lower part is repeated
here right
and in fact you can stack as many of
these columns they just call them query
key and value well if i just call them
column one column two
and here this this is like the final
column find f c f right i can in fact
insert column three column four column
five i can insert as many as i want
because it's just repeated right that
there's no
qualitative difference that
differentiates the queries from the keys
in this model right only the values are
a bit different because at the end
they're not aggregated into this global
vector uh with this additive attention
thing
but in essence you know you could do
away completely with for example with
the key column and directly do
the query multiplying them into the
values completely possible so completely
unnecessary
key column now you might think okay if
the key column is unnecessary or if i
can introduce 50 keys in between 50 key
columns that always take the last
whatever global vector and multiply it
in and do additive attention um is this
really an attention mechanism and the
answer is
kind of but not in the way you expect
it's a bit sneaky honestly
see
attention is when i have
well
arguably right who am i to define this
but arguably attention is when i create
one of these things in a dynamic way
and these things are how do i aggregate
information how do i weigh information
from an input sequence okay that is
in essence an attention mechanism
dynamically creating this weighting so
the only way this actually really
happens right here
is
where we're in this w thing right so
this here is in fact the attention
mechanism not the not the not this this
is just a weighted sum like
this here is
the
the hidden attention mechanism with
it's essentially a self-attention
mechanism right you can you can see
so the alpha eyes are how do we
aggregate information
and then
okay i guess
yeah
this belongs to the attention mechanism
but
uh the keys and the
queries
sorry the keys and the values are both
what they call q right what i aggregate
here those are essentially
the values
the
things to be addressed these are
essentially the keys so the query
is essentially this thing right here
that's that's the query
now the query as you can see is not
dynamic the query is just statically
learned which makes this essentially
into a like a feed forward network or at
best an attention mechanism with a
single
learned query so instead of having n
queries now we have one query per head
and that's why i said the thing at the
very beginning if
if this is applied to a task that
largely relies on you know single-minded
task
global global information tasks and so
on such as sequence classification or
something like this it can be that i
only need a couple of intermediate
really different features per layer
after all they are vector valued so um
which means that if i have
eight heads which have eight different w
vectors and you know there are two w
vectors per layer to be fair there is a
w here and there's also a w again in
this thing right here so every column
gives me essentially a new feature to
extract right so the number of heads
times the number of these columns i have
is essentially the number of features i
can of static features i can extract
from such a sequence
and as i said for global information
tasks that might in fact be enough and
in that case you know
good i can i can get around however i
could have done the same thing
probably by
yeah but by simply constructing less
queries than
um keys and reducing the sequence length
or something like this i mean there are
there are many ways of this but
i i think the thing here is framed in
terms of the words of an attention
mechanism where the actual attention
mechanism is simply like the thing here
that happens inside the queries it's
essentially a self-attention mechanism
on top of the queries with not a dynamic
but one single fixed query the same goes
for column two and then column three is
just kind of like
weird
like it's kind of a weird residual
connection or something where where
there's this this product here with
something that's incoming it's kind of
like a feed forward layer again
um like a dynamic feed forward layer per
token
yeah so
yes that's that's why
i find the name a bit deceptive right
here also to formulate as query key and
value uh here and la and and their whole
talk about who we model the interaction
between something something something
yeah
okay
but what about experiments they're
experiments i find to be relatively
lacking they do have a lot of baseline
comparisons which is respectable their
data sets however appear to be
uh yeah things like sentiment
classification topic classification
tasks
and
it you know they they do perform well i
um you know experimental results are
experimental results and
um
then you know the best numbers are are
achieved by ensembles which is which is
also fine right but even the regular
numbers right here appear to be
quite competitive
so
i don't
exactly
know
um
yeah the the complexity right here is
also a bit shaky because they sort of
leave away the linear operations and so
on like
yeah
and
as i said there are no
ablations
of
most of the things so there are no
ablations for example of this residual
connection where you just randomly add
the query like why would you do that
like that doesn't even make sense if you
call this
a query
this thing
then
by itself it should carry
no information to pass on by nature of
being a query right so you know why do
you why do you add it up there you know
what's the effect of the individual
columns how many there are right um
you know there are many things to ablate
here to really show why this model
performs well
what they do is they compare sort of the
run time and the
the runtime as the sequence length
increases and as you can see
they're quite
fast right here
which
i guess fast tran is this fast former i
guess fast transformer is fast former um
so and and the regular transformer and
they also are like a constant factor
faster than others
but you know are like
are you a constant factor faster because
you actually don't do
any sort of attention
uh i don't i don't know so yeah that
those are my my two cents uh to this
paper again this might be a neat model
for certain tasks it's certainly fast it
certainly uh doesn't make you run out of
memory as a regular transformer for a
given set of tasks it might in fact work
better than a transformer
my main problem here is with with the
whole framing in terms of attention
um
in terms of the the sort of same
languages trying to pass this off as a
faster transformer
which it is not
all right let me know what you think in
the comments and thanks for listening
bye-bye